welcome to cloud on air live webinar
some Google cloud and this is CET V or
hosting webinars every Tuesday my name
is yuri Greenstein I'm a cloud customer
engineer here at Google and today I'm
joined by spoons the CTO and co-founder
of light step to talk about
observability and distributed
applications you can ask questions
anytime on the platform and we have
folks on standby already to answer them
so let's get started so first of all
spoons thank you so much for being here
today appreciate it my pleasure it's
great to be here all right so let's talk
about micro services sure I think a lot
of folks think for them as kind of the
ultimate answer to all of their problems
what do you think yeah there's a lot of
great things about micro services or
villus other sort of modern
architectures I think it lets you scale
lets you divide the work among your team
in a lot of ways so yeah it's great yeah
but I'm assuming that we wouldn't be
here today if they were perfect that's
right I think as much as that micro
services help you who move quickly um
you kind of often lose the big picture
or what's actually happening in your
application yeah and I think one of the
ways you lose is sort of one of the
issues you have is around observability
right and the more services you have the
more stuff you have talking to each
other there is to understand what's
going on yeah especially if you kind of
step back and think of it from your
users point of view users don't care how
many micro services are involved they
don't care about the experience they
have and that's gonna cut across all of
your services in a way that maybe your
traditional tools are not taking account
yeah so what are some of the durability
challenges that you've seen with micro
services architectures yeah I mean I
think it really starts from just the
tools themselves so I think you know
when you think about what's happening
you know we saw this tweet that I think
is pretty funny you know I replaced our
monolith with a micro services and that
turns every outage into a murder mystery
that's really kind of coming from the
fact that you know people kind of look
at these three tools in terms or three
sets of tools and how they look at
observability mmm-hmm metrics logging in
tracing sort of three approaches to how
you might see what's going on inside the
application itself so let's talk about
those three so first metrics write their
time series data you know what are they
useful for what what do they tell us
about what's happening within
our application ya metrics are great for
understanding when something has gone
wrong um it's great easy to set
thresholds alerts things like that you
can get notified they're not so great
about understanding why something's gone
wrong so you know it's easy to tell that
it might be correlated failures but
understanding the causes of failures can
be pretty hard alright so yeah I think
it's a good way of describing it right
metrics tell us when something happens
yeah so how do we find out what is
happening yeah so again traditionally
maybe you look at a logging tool to do
something like that
logging is great about giving a ton of
detail about a specific transaction or
maybe within a specific service mm-hm
and yeah it can give you that detail I
think the you know the the downside of
it is really the volume of data that you
might have there sure all right so get
metrics we've got logs
what about traces traces are good it's
sort of the new kid on the block if you
like in this in some ways um one of my
co-founders built a system at Google
called dapper which was Google's
distributed tracing system and Deborah
was great for understanding the latency
and some of the other issues that were
coming up in Google's web search and
able to really like identify for a
particular search where was the latency
where is the slowness coming from you
know you do a search as a user you don't
think about it but there's you know web
Doc's there's news there's personal
results there's images there's all kinds
of things that are sort of feeding into
that any one of those things could be a
problem at any time sure all right so we
got our metrics to tell us kind of what
is going on in the win
we've got logs that allow us to
understand errors and you know specific
events we've got traces that tell us
what our latency is it's then we have
distributed Tracy which can tells us
what's the latency between different
micro services yeah all right so why is
observability still a problem yeah so
each of these things has kind of their
own problems in a way so really to take
advantage of metrics you want to be able
to dig in a bit and understand you know
is this problem only occurring in the
latest releases or incurred in all
releases okay well how do I do that
right I tagged it right it bhagadatta so
now I can sort of segment by different
releases probably also want a segment
maybe by host or data center so I can
figure out if there's some sort of
infrastructure problem sure a lot of
folks included you know will tag based
upon customer IDs but these things
yes exactly and you know when you think
about the way that a metrics tool is
built really it has to keep track of
every one of these individual streams
and really the kind of full cross
product of all those things every
different combination and this is what
folks kind of refer to as sort of the
cardinality problem in a sense sure all
right so metrics too good because they
tell us when things are happening but
it's hard to keep track of them
especially you got a big system yeah the
service has lots of customers lots of
metrics all right
well surely logs don't have any problems
yeah they might have a few so logs are
great but you really end up paying by
volume um and if the amount of logging
that you're generating is just
proportional to the amount of service
that you're providing cool
that's just like fixed cost then it's no
problem we can think about that but as
the complexity of your service grows and
you start building out sort of a micro
services or similar architecture you're
gonna want to add more logging for each
new micro service that you add so now
the amount of logging they're generating
is not just proportional to the traffic
that you're serving to your users but
also to the complexity of what you're
building and that means either your
costs are going to go way up or if you
fix your costs you're gonna have to
reduce the amount of logging that you do
so you can little use things like
sampling yeah or even just you know I
know folks that won't log in some
environments like they just don't get
their staging environment because it's
too expensive that's unfortunate because
you know that could be really valuable
in diagnosing problems in that
environment it's hard to reproduce a
problem outside of production if you
don't have logging turned on in those
environments yeah exactly exactly so all
right so logs don't necessarily scale as
well all right let's talk about traces
what are the issues in here yeah yeah so
at least in the way traces were built it
and Google and the way that they are
built in depper is they were actually
looking at a pretty narrow problem which
is looking at for web search how do we
understand overall latency sure and it
turns out Google does like a bazillion
requests every second and so you can
actually throw away a lot of the data
and still get a pretty good signal and
so for Debra actually the costs were not
in terms of the overhead in the
application itself
so that is like in web search Google
still I think anyway basically doing the
instrumentation every request that comes
in the thing it turns out to be
expensive is actually just touring all
oh yeah that make sense I could see how
that could be a lot of data yeah so
with in-depth kind of the default mode
anyway is that you throw out 99.9% of
the data almost immediately and then you
throw out another 90% so you're down to
99.9% of the data is thrown out is it a
tiny fraction with luck and again like
you know point of 1% of a bazillion is
still like it's still a big number yeah
but now you start to miss out on some of
the finer detail where it's like okay
well you know if you're just looking in
aggregate across all of googles requests
great but if we want to start talking
about maybe a different use case where
you've got um these interesting segments
of different customers you're interested
in sort of small fraction your customers
the the chances of that small fraction
overlapping with this point on one
percent are starting to get small yeah
so I can see some of the challenges that
we're starting to identify right it's
hard to keep track of lots of different
metrics it's hard to keep all the logs
just because of the amount of data we
have to store how much it costs you know
whether you're paying you know your
infrastructure cost to yourself and when
your data center or to someone like
Google to store them it's still a lot
and then traces all of it also create a
lot of data is that right yeah so that
mean I think you actually hit it right
there I mean the way that we kind of
think about these at light stuff is that
metrics logs and traces are just data as
much as like people kind of in the past
of thought about it was three separate
tools that you've got in your tool belt
mm-hmm there's a lot of opportunities to
really look at where you can use them to
interact and leverage aspects of metrics
and how you do log collection look at
how log collection or how logs can be
combined with traces and that way you
can sort of look more holistically like
what are the problems that were actually
trying to solve you know as an
observability - yeah it's not what I
feel like I'm at that person in the
infomercial who's like struggling I'm
like dropping things I'm trying to chop
vegetables I don't know what I'm doing
and then the announcer comes on and says
you know surely there must be a better
way there's a knife for that all right
so tell me about the better way sure
so let's just do kind of a quick demo so
this is sort of one view into what we
can show and light step so this is kind
of a demo app that we've put together so
what we're doing is we're monitoring
application here which does some sort of
reservation system right so cars or
seats or tickets or something like that
but anyway there's you know the app
there's a bunch of Micra services on the
backend and what we can do is we can
look at it across a bunch of different
and so here we're looking at a
particular set of requests that are
coming from that iOS app okay things
look pretty flat right everything seems
to be to be consistent and fine here
yeah so sort of kind of three parts of
what we're doing on the top looking at
latency which is sort of the slowness
how long is taking the respondent
requests below that the rate of requests
and then below that the error rate and
so rates pretty steady no errors are
happening so that's all good and looking
at latency yeah it's pretty flat what
we're doing here is we're only showing
though the median latency okay so that's
basically you know sort of 50th percent
percentile of what we're doing if we
sort of step back a little bit we can
actually in light step looking not just
at 50th percentile but look at these
higher percentiles above that so we can
look at 95th percentile 99th percentile
or even 99.9 percent I'll look at those
actually there's a lot more story to
tell about what's going on here yeah so
this is actually showing you a very
different picture right even though I
mean Lea and C is very flat and there's
really nothing happening there when we
start going going to the high
percentiles it really looks like there
was there was an event here there was a
billion C spike and I ain't see sort of
almost crashed and then it evened out
back to kind of its expected value yeah
yeah that's a very different picture
that you get when you look at those
higher percentiles than what you get
when you just look at the median yeah
and that's I think super important
especially in a distributed system one
of the reasons is that these high
percentile agencies are often sort of
bellwethers for what's gonna happen for
most of your users later on so these are
really users that are kind of pushing
the envelope in a way and you know as
your overall traffic grows hopefully
it's not just gonna be one percent of
users that are experiencing that it's
gonna be more but if you can get ahead
of it and fix it for those one percent
before it becomes a wider set problem
that's great the second thing is when
you're building a distributed system you
know we're really just looking at one
component here and we're looking and
seeing that 1% of the requests to that
particular component or slow but if you
think about it from a user's perspective
there were transaction the request is
going to hit a whole bunch of different
services you know so if each of those
has 1% that's low the chances that a
user is actually having a bad experience
we're going to go up and up and up so
maybe in an individual service it's only
1% of requests but it you know if
there's 20 services you know it's gonna
be 20% of requests that are gonna abuse
all right so next obvious question I
know that we're having some latency
issues why what's going on yeah so I
think um you know this I kind of think
of latency the latency measurements that
my stuff does is kind of table stakes
and all like it's got to do this I think
one of the cool things that like step
adds on top is that we're actually also
keeping a record of transactions across
these different land seas and actually
using the latency as a kind of signal to
tell what might be an interesting
transaction to go look at mhm
so each of these little dots here
represent some transaction where we've
captured a complete trace for that okay
that's a that's a lot of traces yeah I
mean we pick what we think as a kind of
representative sample we don't expect a
human to look at all of these what the
way that I kind of think of it is like
sort of automated crime-scene
investigation so you know you're the
detective you know that something's gone
wrong
you've got this robot that'll come in
and do this like you know both you know
get good coverage kind of evidence
gathering but also be a little bit
intelligent like it's not gonna help you
to get like you know ten thousand
fingerprint samples you want ten right
right you're the important ones exactly
so in this we actually try to bias if we
were just picking sort of arbitrarily
like most of them would be down here at
the bottom in fact half of them would be
below the bottom line we actually biased
towards these longer ones so even though
these requests way up kind of the top
here represent say only you know 0.01
0.05 percent of the requests we're gonna
capture those more frequently than that
okay so tell me more about that biasing
because this sounds like something very
different than I've seen other
monitoring tools do yeah it's a little
bit tricky to get right and it's
actually kind of feeds into a bit about
the way we built it but really the idea
is that you want to understand as much
about the transaction as possible before
you decide whether or not it's going to
be something that a human is gonna
launch okay yeah and slowness is a great
signal to use unfortunately you don't
know if request is slow until it's done
that's right so and you need to be
capturing the trace as is happening now
when it's done exactly so there's kind
of time travel that we have to do to
make that happen
it is pretty different than the way but
yeah you finally you did it yeah in a
pretty narrow case but we got we got a
kind of time travel um the way Deborah
kind of took this approach is that like
again there's a bazillion requests
they're all kind of the same it doesn't
matter which they actually made this
decision right when the request started
okay
and we make it
or even you know it can be you know
seconds or minutes after the request
ends where there's something else that's
interesting that we thought is sort of
relevant to a human trying to debug
what's going on okay so cool so now show
me what happened you know what are we
seeing when we're capturing these
transactions yeah so let me dig in on
one of these things so this is a request
that took about seven seconds and we're
showing kind of a trace of what you can
think of it like a kind of a Gantt chart
or you know we've got a chrome debugger
or something like that at the top what
we have is a sort of a summary of what's
going on breaking down each of the
services at a different color and just
looking pretty quickly at this I can
tell this purple service here that's
really the bottleneck that's what's
taking looks like more than five seconds
of this request um so if I click into
that like it's more data I can see this
is in this is an API server it's doing
something called user space mapping
mm-hmm and now if I want to see you know
what why that's happened well I've got a
bunch of additional detail I've got some
tags I've got some logs that are
associated with this particular request
and I can see yet so this is because
we're doing some sort of connection
pooling pool is exhausted we stalled
yeah so it's really valuable to have
this information sort of all in the same
context right you've got the trace for
the service that's telling you how long
things took but then you're pulling in
the log data that's telling you exactly
why it took as long as it did yeah in
this case is because yeah we rotted out
of connections yeah exactly so this kind
of gets to what we think of the two kind
of fundamental activities in this one is
measurement tending you know when
something is happening with something
gone wrong and the other is explaining
what's happening and Yung able to get to
kind of the root cause of these things
so one of the things you may need to do
is to understand alright so we knew that
when we captured this trace here was the
problem how representative is this of
everything else that's going on yeah
exactly like is this still happening
yeah so one of the things you know we
have this kind of time travel in a sense
what we can do is we can look at all the
requests for this particular service
that occurred over say the last five are
at five or ten minutes and then we can
kind of break that down here we're
showing a histogram not a time series so
this is trying to sort of plot that
population you can kind of see there's
such a kind of a funny shape here it's
not totally smooth it looks like there's
sort of maybe two distinct things that
are happening based upon that shape so
what I can do is I can kind of filter
look at some of those I can compare to
what it looked like before
maybe fake
a little bit over the last hour that's
really useful um and now I've got a
bunch of examples of these kinds of
transactions that have occurred recently
in the last minute or so and I can get a
quick summary of like what the problems
here might be um again it looks like
this user space mapping thing still a
problem for these for these slower
transactions all right very cool so this
looks great obviously it takes a lot of
data and a lot of processing to make all
this happen yeah so how does light step
actually work yeah yeah yeah so we've
got kind of logically anyway this what
we what we think of as a hybrid
architecture so certainly part of light
stuff is as a SAS tool but part of it
also is an on-prem component so we call
that on from the satellites and the
satellites are really gathering data
from all kinds of different sources it
could be you know from your micro
services it could be that we patched in
with your monolith because you probably
still have one of those everyone
everyone still has at least one you know
and we've even passion with other
logging tools and things like that and
as well as gathering data from from
clients and all of that data goes to the
satellite so this is where we were a
little bit different than something like
Deborah where even at that point within
the application itself some sampling was
already happening for life stuff all of
this data gets to the satellites so the
cell is getting this crazy firehose of
data and they're holding on to it just
for a few minutes basically long enough
for us by coordinating through the south
side of things to understand whether not
there's anything interesting there okay
so tell me what's happening once the
satellites kind of do their magic they
send the data to to the cloud yeah
what's happening there yeah so a couple
things one was we're collecting the
statistics of do things like show you
p99 the other thing that we're doing is
sending requests back to the satellite
section so it's sort of a bi-directional
protocol that we do because it might not
be that something was interesting in
itself it was actually perfectly fine
but it provides important context for
understanding why something else was
slow you can think of this as kind of an
online stream processing system okay
that makes sense all right so then the
next logical question is you know this
the the SAS the cloud component is built
on Google cloud that's right yeah how
did you do that yeah so you know I kind
of think about we know where we want to
put our time from
is a kind of engineering organization
where do we want to use things off the
shelf that are that are meeting our
needs and where do we need to add our
you're kind of making sauce so I see
you've got kubernetes on here yeah yeah
cloud sequel and spanner as well yes I'm
really interested in all of this let's
talk about kubernetes Charis right
obviously this is something about lots
and lots of folks are interested in like
everyone's building stuff in kubernetes
tell me about how how did you arrive at
kind of building things on kubernetes
yeah if you kind of go way way way back
to kind of the very beginning of light
stuff you know we you know we had our
monolith in the beginning we didn't we
didn't start with anything too fancy we
had a little bash shell script that we
used to do Shermy deployments and
eventually that shell script became not
such a little script anymore I'd only
put the first few lines around here the
rest of it's a little bit embarrassing
but we got to a point where like I was
just you know it was getting there's too
many ways to fail too many ways just you
know I don't I don't know how to test
for this kind of thing right and I
that's right right start anything that
you're using in production should be
tested and the one you're having to
write test for your shell scripts then
the new you're in a tough place yeah not
the right place so the word I was kind
of think about that time as I wanted to
kind of leap frog ahead like I didn't
want to skip you know I don't I want to
date myself by saying you know where I
think shell scripts come from exactly
but you know I didn't want to skip to
like you know 2004 or anything that I
wanted to skip you know right - whatever
2016-2017 and so for me that wasn't like
let's kind of set a lot of this sort of
configuration management aside and just
going straight to something like
kubernetes okay so how did you end up
deploying on kubernetes in production
did you end up using like one big
cluster do you have lots of smaller
clusters how did you come make those
decisions
yeah in several times maybe however but
I mean we started with one I guess you
know obviously that's where you always
start from I think we thought about
building out a bunch of them at some
point where I kind of arrived at as I
think it's nice to have to and always
you know as much as like we so we use
container engine and container engine
automates a lot of things and it runs
the master and like I'm super happy that
someone else is monitoring that yeah I
kind of think for me but there is you
know you still have to understand what's
going
you still you know node upgrades are
super easy but someone still gotta you
got to do it and click that button so I
didn't really want to be a state where
like every engineer was managing their
own communities cluster that it's too
many on the other hand I like having a
couple so that we can test out you know
new node version things like that in a
non customer-facing environment ok so
you basically have like one we'll call
like test and I want production cluster
kind of thing roughly I mean the test
ones used for a lot of things not just
though testing integration testing is
used for a bunch of developer things um
you know other folks of the company want
to pull this stuff they can do it
they're you know it lets us keep that
thing pretty open as well there's no
customer data and that so it's like if
you want to play with it go ahead okay
so given that your infrastructure is
relatively straightforward how did you
end up splitting the team the
responsibility is to do things like you
know even that one cluster week you said
still requires two management right
someone has to decide to operate the
knows
yeah hearses someone else that says ok
here's the code that were yeah that
we're pushing so how did you end up like
giving up those are those rules yeah so
we have certainly some experts and these
kinds of things who you know who are
kind of keeping track of that and and
are aware of you know when we need to do
upgrades and things like that and
probably handle a lot of that but I
didn't really want to create a team
whose job was just to do that in a sense
like I mean maybe when we're bigger
we get to scale of other companies will
have to do that kind of thing but to me
like I wanted to keep DevOps or sree to
be a super collaborative I'm kind of
engagement and that means that like our
our SES actually are sort of embedded in
teams and do some small amounts of
product development work as part of it
and I think that actually helps them
build a lot of empathy for their
customer and share with other engineers
it lights done yeah they make sense
right when you're responsible for
supporting this thing but you've also
been the one to figure out what to what
to push the production yeah you're
operating under the same you know solos
and air budgets yeah and that's your
empathy is exactly super-important
exactly exactly
ok very cool so now let's let's talk
about the backend yeah you got a lot of
data coming into the system that's right
where's it going yeah that's the hard
part I think if you don't have
persistence like everything's pretty
easy so I mean there's a lot there's a
come there's some stories in this I
think you know back in the back in the
day when light step was just a demo and
just a pilot like you know we started
just developing from our laptops right
sure and so we were running
my sequel locally it's pretty easy and
we put a ton of data in there probably
some data that shouldn't have been there
but but it was a demo right so yeah it's
moving fast I think this is the thing
that always kind of like that haunts me
but I think back about like we've been
kind of continuously operating might
step from those very early pilot days
and that's pretty fairly common right
startups you you kind of come you often
come out of something like a hackathon
you've got this thing that you build
overnight yeah and suddenly you're doing
you know sales calls to customers and
exactly good production part of me you
know the engineer deep inside like wants
to like make a clean start no sorry to
like that but I just you know there's no
time and it's probably not the right
place anyway it's never the right time
to start stretch yeah so a lot of the
stuff is in my sequel definitely some
things that shouldn't be one of those
was a bunch of time series data yeah not
not super high frequency but like still
time series data itself and when we
moved into cloud we were really starting
to overwhelm the cloud sequel stores
with this the right rate and you know
keeping up with replication and things
like yeah and this so it's interesting
that you've been our time series and
right rate because whenever I talk to
customers that have that particular
problem in their environment I would say
hey BigTable was built to do just that
yeah and yeah you've got it on on your
slide here so you're kind of doing do my
pitch for me yeah yeah yeah we actually
took kind of a long path through these
which maybe not not totally evident so
we actually moved to Cassandra first
this was actually before BigTable with
the products oh okay that was sort of
where we were first feeling the pain
around this and Cassandra was great in a
lot of ways I though I think in
retrospect I never want to sort of
underestimate the amount of expertise
that's required to run a distributed
storage system yeah that makes sense
so we actually got into a pretty bad
state with Cassandra so we run a couple
of different environments one of them we
call meta which is the light step
environment that monitors the other
light step environments okay that sounds
important yeah yeah I mean for us it's
important to understand our customers
depend on us to be up and understand
their systems we got to be available so
the Cassandra cluster that we were
running as part of the meta environment
got into a state where one of the nodes
is corrupted and we had not done a great
job of some of the configuration and it
was basically gonna be a significant
outage for us to recover that thing and
that was again non customer and facing
non customer facing environments and
weak
we could make it work but probably
pattern you want to be yeah exactly I
didn't you know what was gonna stop this
from happening in our space so we
actually wanted to move pretty quickly
to get out of that state and migrate our
data elsewhere so we actually did some
evaluation of a big table and a spanner
at that point and kind of looked at like
you know what are the costs going to be
what are the sort of overhead in terms
of the the latency that that's going to
introduce into our product and you know
what are the kind of different features
that are available in those so actual
when I come back a spanner but tell me
more about that evaluation yeah so how
did you do it on what did you see
we actually used light stuff itself to
do some of that evaluation which was
pretty fun so this is just showing
latency for the reeds against Cassandra
and against spanner
okay the big day the ones we ended up
reproducing some of this actually looked
fairly similar to the Cassandra one
analyst maybe not super surprisingly but
yeah I think this kind of gets back to
what we were talking about before about
the difference between P 50 and P 99
latency so you know if you look at the
median latency Cassandra's act a little
bit faster which I'm sort of expected
it's in the same roster I think and so
it was you know looking median was about
two and a half that's pretty fast
yeah it was great and cool it's been are
a little bit slower about six or seven
milliseconds still pretty fast still
pretty fast totally within bounds for
what we needed in terms of our
application in the performance yeah but
if you look at those longer tailed
agencies actually there's this huge
spread and kind of shown in the graph
here sorted by the distance between the
lines on the Cassandra side that the P
99 latency was two orders of magnitude
bigger that's pretty big distribution so
one percent of them were actually you
know 250 milliseconds okay on the
spanner side incredibly tight so
spammers just had this really
predictable behavior and to us that was
kind of a comforting thing yeah it's
only I think you know the decision you
made right it's better to be slightly
slower but completely predictably so
then a bit faster but much less
predictive yeah yeah and there were some
other features around kind of
replications were available it's better
at the time anyway that were also pretty
sure after all right so let's go back a
step because one thing is I'm really
interested in is kind of how are you
using spanner right is a conversation
that I have with customers pretty
frequently that basically think that
spanner is basically kind of the next
relational database and so if I'm in
nightclub sequel today then spanner you
know once I get to a certain size span
there's just sort of the logical next
step right and they just think of it as
a it's a big sort of globally consistent
relational database but the thing they
really care about is that it's just a
man it's okay fully manage relational
yeah and then you have different
customers or different yeast cases where
they what they really care about is that
global consistency isn't it that's
absolutely what they need and the only
way you get that shortly in GP is on
span and I think only given in the world
quite honestly yeah yeah where did you
kind of end up how how did you make your
decision
yeah it was kind of a mix of those I
think so part of it was we were being a
bit reactive you know we had this
cluster that could fail at any moment
you have to do something yeah so we need
to do something and I think spanner had
the flexibility to make that migration
pretty easy okay I think for all these
things you know light stuff's gonna
change a lot we're gonna build some new
cool stuff in the future cool clouds
gonna offer a lot of cool stuff in the
future too we're gonna make more
migrations and so to me the thing that
was really attractive about spanner I
guess part of it was the the kind of
global replication and that made us feel
good about not having the data wherever
we needed it but really putting us in
control in terms of when we were gonna
have to migrate again and you knowing
that it was gonna scale yeah so whatever
we needed yeah it's much better to do
the migration when you think you're
ready rather than when your
infrastructure says exactly exactly so
we can plan you know this quarter we're
gonna do future are we gonna do
migration no we're gonna push the
migration office if you want and be
comfortable knowing that there's gonna
scale to that all right very cool all
right so we've talked about you're not
shy why did you want to ask one more
question that I forgot to ask you about
on the companies and I don't know if you
want to get into this now can you tell
me a little bit about how you're doing
multi-tenancy in kubernetes yeah it's a
mix so we have some things where we do
share tenancy where you know there's
relatively low overhead in terms of
we're really not all over but just like
low computational cost of what we need
to do and we also have cases where we
want to more isolation and we use a
combination of labels and some painting
to make that happen
yeah awesome all right so we're starting
to get kind of near the end here this is
a lot of really good stuff here I think
you know you learn some really
interesting really important lessons as
you've got
you know first got into the cloud of
them kind of made some technology
changes and technology migrations you
know if you were to leave you know our
audience was just a couple of things
that you think they should learn from
your experience yeah whoa daddy yeah so
I think one of them you kind of asking
about a bit like what was the kind of
cluster architecture that we set up I
really like for all these kinds of
questions the number two because one is
probably not enough it doesn't give you
a chance to test things out so 10 or 20
is probably a lot you know let's get
back to what you're talking about what
you don't want every engineer to have to
manage their own cluster exactly but I
think you know going back there's some
things that I might have thought a
little bit harder about and I would
encourage other people to do and
thinking about you know how are you
gonna be able to attribute these
infrastructure cost to your customers
yeah that's something that is
interesting to you I bet it's gonna be
interesting to your CFO someday yeah
thinking about how you're breaking up
billing in terms of you know where are
you spending money on customer facing
environments and where are you spending
money on a load test just being able to
understand that over time is really
important I think that's you know
influence some of our decisions around
kubernetes but also in the storage
itself when do you create a new instance
when you make a new bucket yeah yeah
that makes sense
the other thing I was thinking about a
bit and something I would like to
continue to do better for us even is
just kind of step back and think about
the big picture around storage like I
sort of described in terms of how we
kind of got to spanner like you know
that code you know follow this path from
you know my sequel to Cassandra spanner
and you know there's a legacy there in a
sense that like we that code was
originally written with a very different
set of constraints that's right um and I
think you know if you're gonna be at a
point where you know you're gonna be on
one of these hosted systems which i
think is a great great thing about
productivity really thinking about how
the features that are only available in
those platforms could actually influence
the kinds of features that you built so
some of the more interesting features of
spanner things around bigquery like
there's a lot of things that you can do
that really cool that you can't do on
your lab test right and that I think
would be great to think about when
you're designing features and that
product you want to build yeah I know
obviously the trade-off there then is
this concept of lock-in right if you're
building stuff with yeah you know
specific GCP features you get a lot of
value out of that but yeah then you're
sort of tied to the platform yeah and I
think you know that's a trade
to make there's a way I think of it it's
just like there's a lot of different
features out there and take advantage of
the last thing you know it as much as
like Cassandra doesn't lock you in in
any way like there's a set of expertise
that we would have had to build around
this room that's an investment there
that we would have to make if they
really want yeah and then the bigger you
get the more critical that Cassandra
system is to your to your customers the
more you have to invest in making sure
that you have folks on staff that can
build that manager exactly Ron Davis
you're gonna make that investment one
way or the other nailing okay cool all
right well thank you so much really
appreciate it
please stay tuned for live Q&A we'll be
back in less than a minute
you
all right well
go through some of our questions so
first question we have is around machine
learning right so are you considering to
using kind of machine learning to
improve something information that
you're providing to your users yeah is
the question we get a lot actually um
machine learning and observability I
think is a really tricky thing yeah you
know being wrong in a way where you've
woken up an engineer at 3 o'clock in the
morning oh no it wasn't a problem sorry
it's pretty different in the confidence
that an engineer's gonna have in that
system is going to go down really fast
for those kinds of false positives I
think the way that we think about lights
up a lot is kind of a guide so other wit
places where we can use machine learning
to better surface the kinds of facts and
sort of evidence that can help you make
a decision but really putting those
facts in front of you for you as a human
to choose because in the end like you
just have state that the machines don't
have in terms of you know it's right
where the release has happened and sort
of the organization how the software's
devolved all those kinds of things yeah
I'm gonna go back to things like SRB
principles right the idea is that you
want to spend all the time upfront
identifying your SLO is your slis and
then when you're doing things like
alerting it's also something that you
you've designed very intentionally
exactly exactly yeah awesome all right
so we started out talking about micro
services did you build lace up on using
micro sorry yeah not from the beginning
I think we started from you know a
single static link go binary and that
actually you know we actually still have
pieces of that today which you know it's
living on and is sort of a continual
challenge and a place where we have to
invest in our in our own infrastructure
but yeah I don't think I I mean as much
as micro services it can be great in a
lot of ways if you're one person sitting
your laptop like you know what your
surfaces are about scaling they're about
you know dividing up your application
away that like maps into your
organizational structure right now
they're about fault isolation if you're
running everything on your laptop with
you coding it like none of those things
are valuables right so it's so something
you have to have a lot of foresight when
you're first starting out so if you're
literally just one person building a
laptop you have to think about what is
my life going if this thing works what
is my life going to be like a year from
now yeah you have to think if you want
to kind of go down that route you have
to be very much forward thinking it's
hard to do that when you're yeah and
there's some investment in doing that
right
that slows things down we've got to
deploy multiple services when before it
was just to push this naval binary so
alright cool
one more question I think we have time
for you know obviously we've talked a
lot about what you're doing in GCP are
you running lights up in the multi cloud
wait or not yeah so part of it does run
today like in that we have this kind of
hybrid architecture so you know
certainly some of our customers run
parts of light stuff on other cloud
providers they run in on bare metal and
their own data centers and so in some
ways we actually feel kind of we get the
advantages and all of the pain from
prodding both from software and SSS
solution but yeah I think as we move
forward like kind of getting back to
what we're saying about lock-in like you
know I just see these as opportunities
so if there's places where we can you
know get value by using a solution on a
different cloud provider that's great
like that's part of what micro services
really offers as a way to build
applications all right awesome hey thank
you so much for being here today really
appreciate it yeah no it's a pleasure
thanks all right folks
please stay tuned for the next session
which is going to cover google docs tips
and tricks to boost your productivity
thank you very much